next is gonna be Gina in Ohio
hi Gina welcome to Dave Ramsey show hi
thank you for taking my call I
appreciate it sure I'm trying to figure
out if I should smile bankruptcy or try
to negotiate a settlement with a bank
I'm recently divorced with finalized in
the summer my ex-husband agreed to in
this is Alan but it's the divorce
decreed it he would take on the debts
and the assets so he got the house and
the loans and the money that we'd taken
out for his business opportunities but
he also got to keep those assets however
he has since had some trouble in his
career and he is high P defaulted on his
loan it's a personal loan but we had
taking it out for business purposes and
he never refinanced my name off of it
now he was supposed to approve the
divorce decree so now the bank is coming
after me because I'm a cosigner on the
loan and they want me to pay it's going
to end up somewhere between 250 to 300
thousand dollars and I don't have any of
those assets to sell off in society but
they know he does have some of the
assets and he could sell them off but
he's kind of put himself in his own
little witness protection program he
changed his last name and he moved and
he has not left a forwarding address I
am getting his mail even though we're
divorced and and I've moved as well
we've both both left the state and so
they don't want to track him down
because that's harder I don't want them
to I want you to and I want the judge to
put him in jail for violating the he's
in contempt of court on the divorce
decree I want you to hire a private
investigator I want you to find him and
I want you to have your lawyer file a
motion with the court that he's in
contempt on the divorce decree he's
holding assets that will pay this deep
bill and he's a shyster indeed okay yeah
that's that's the best answer for your
question if you may end up if you can't
get this done and you
but I don't I'm not gonna just roll over
and be yet another one of his victims
so our private investigator and go for
the jugular and and call your old
divorce attorneys your older divorce
attorney a little bit mean she's a shark
yeah
good good that's what I want I don't
want a nice attorney I don't want a mean
one if I need an attorney I don't need a
need somebody be nice I'll get a pastor
but uh so yeah if I need an attorney I
need an attorney so that yeah that's
what you need to do it just let's just
grab this guy by the throat which is how
only thing he understands and shake his
turned him upside down shaking until
he's nickels fall out of his pockets
yeah I mean that that's where I would
spend my energy before I went to
bankruptcy court now again you just tell
the bank look here send a bank a copy of
the divorce decree it does not relieve
you from the liability that's the
problem with divorce decrees people do
the deal like you've done all the time
they think they're free only they find
out later that they're still on all
these notes and divorce decree does not
have the power to remove your liability
on these notes which is what you've
discovered but I would send him a copy
of that divorce decree anyway and say
notice he got the assets I don't have
any assets and so what's going to happen
if you pressure means you're gonna get a
goose egg from me because I'm gonna file
a chapter 7 oh by the way you're getting
a goose egg from me either way I'm not
paying this bill so either you go find
him or we go find him I'm gonna work on
finding him and we get some money out of
him but I don't have to earn $50,000 and
you yelling at me doesn't make me
doesn't make it create 250,000 in my
bedroom it doesn't happen I go in there
there's a stack of Benjamin's it didn't
happen okay so you know just talk to the
bank like this and go in other words you
guys have got to be kidding me I'm a
newly divorced lady
I have zero assets he got all the assets
you did the deal with him anyway which
makes you stupid
and you guys need to go find him he's
your problem I got zero I couldn't pay
you if I wanted to I don't want to and
I'm not going to and if you pursue it
too much I'm just gonna give you a big
bankruptcy a big BK right there
4head and so back off and let's go find
this guy and get the assets out of him
so you can get paid that's how I would
talk to the bank okay and should I
continue to represent myself speaking to
the bank or should I hire an attorney
it's okay if you do because you're not
really you know just tell them what I
just told you this the thing you want to
do is be a little your just a real nice
person and I don't want you to be that
in this conversation I want you to be
really tough okay I don't want you being
arrogant or nasty but I just want you to
kind of be sarcastic and edgy like I was
when I was speaking it over you a minute
ago okay I want you to be that lady and
go you gotta be kidding me
I'm not paying you I don't have any
money number one number two you bozos
did the deal with him go find him I'm
looking for him too you find him let me
know if I find him I'll let you know I'm
not giving you nothing